ja und in Zürich grüße ich jetzt den
militärökonomen Markus Matthias Keup der
russische Präsident Putin der hat nach
einem vermeintlichen sabotage-akte
Nationalen Sicherheitsrat einberufen es
heißt von ukrainischen sabotieren ist da
die Rede und von mehreren getöteten
russischen Zivilisten wissen sie da
vielleicht näheres
guten Abend ja man hat zuerst gedacht es
wäre eine Force Flag Operation der
Russen aber nach allem was wir jetzt
wissen sind ist russische Neonazis die
sich da inszeniert haben
es ist vielleicht etwas stark aufgebaut
worden in den Medien also wesentlichen
Einfluss auf den Kriegsverlauf hat es
nicht aber die Russen versuchen
natürlich das auszuschlachten im Sinne
von informationsoperation könnte das
vielleicht für irgendwelche
militärischen neuen Operationen ein
Vorwand sein
nicht wirklich nein also diese diese
russischen Neonazis die kämpfen zwar in
Ihrem eigenen Interesse auf Seiten der
Ukraine aber nicht im Rahmen der
regulären ukrainischen Truppen also vor
allem nicht in der ukrainischen
Fremdenlegion sie werden ja wie soll ich
sagen sie werden von Russland halt
benutzt um zu um zu begründen also in
Anführungszeichen dass die ganze Ukraine
natürlich nach wie vor voll sei mit
Nazis und man deswegen die
spezialoperation weiterführen müsste
also das ist so ein bisschen was was die
Russen versuchen zu konstruieren es ist
natürlich genauso lächerlich wie die
ganze Reihe dieser Behauptungen aber es
macht halt Eindruck in den Medien der
ukrainische
verteidigungsministerkopf er hat heute
erklärt die Kampfjet die wird die
Ukraine sicherlich bekommen früher oder
später das sei genauso was wie mit den
Leopard Panzern und der russische
frühere macht aber im Grunde nicht Wette
hat gesagt also wenn Kampfjets dann wäre
das der Eintritt des Westen S in den
Krieg
ja kurze ich nehme mit wär dir schon
lange nicht mehr ernst aber ich meine
ich empfehle den Zuschauern immer wenn
sie mal einen Spaß haben wollen googlen
sie mal Russland droht mit nuklear Krieg
und zwar seit 2018 da finden sie diese
diese ganzen Hinweise
sie können genau das gleiche sagen mit
ähm wenn der Westen XY macht dann ist
das der Eintritt in den Krieg also diese
Verlautbarung haben wir ständig die sind
Teil der normalen russischen Propaganda
aber sie merken eben im kremme sitzt ein
Deutschland Kenner einen ehemaliger
Checkliste lange in Ostdeutschland
stationiert war und der weiß ganz genau
wie man mit deutschen Ängsten spielt es
ist immer wieder dasselbe ich bin
überrascht dass es immer wieder
funktioniert immer wieder in den Medien
thematisiert wird aber natürlich ist das
nicht der Eintritt in den Krieg sondern
das läuft nach wie vor unter Artikel 51
der un-kater abgesehen davon hat die
Ukraine auch eigene
langstreckenmittel das haben wir gerade
heute gesehen also z.B die Drohne jetzt
die ja bis kurz vor Moskau geflogen ist
ohne dass die russische Luftabwehr das
merkt also man muss auch nicht immer so
dieses narrativ bringen der Westen tut
dies der Westen tut das die Ukraine ist
im Moment dabei auch ihre eigenen
Kapazitäten und Waffensysteme durchaus
schlagfest zu entwickeln der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister hat heute auch
noch gesagt also er will die Ukraine
wieder haben in den Grenzen von 1991 das
würde also bedeuten mit allen der Zeit
von Russland besetzten Gebieten im Osten
des Landes und natürlich auch die Krim
und Verhandlungen mit Russland mit Putin
die schließt er kategorisch aus
also die Verhandlungen die braucht er
eigentlich gar nicht kategorisch
auszuschließen weil die Russen das
bereits mehrfach selbst getan haben also
sowohl durch die Medien als auch durch
Klarstellung des russischen
Außenministeriums Russland ist derzeit
der Ansicht es gibt überhaupt nichts zu
verhandeln wir führen unsere sogenannten
spezialoperationen hier durch bis zum
Ende also sie sehen verhandeln ist nicht
das Thema auch wenn das gewisse Menschen
in Deutschland vielleicht anders sehen
aber natürlich ist das das Kriegsziel
der Ukraine die
Neutralisierung der russischen
Aggression und ich sage das immer wieder
diese Aggression beginnt nicht 20 22 sie
beginnt 20 14 mit der
völkerrechtswidrigen Invasion der Grimm
und der sogenannten Annexion die
natürlich keine ist also diese Gebiete
sind nach wie vor ukrainisches
Staatsgebiete sind seit 20 14 bzw seit
20 22 Völkerrecht besetzt
dementsprechend ist das nicht
überraschend es ist das einzig legitime
Kriegsziel für die Ukraine lassen Sie
uns einmal ganz kurz zum Schluss zu
China kommen die USA haben ja Taiwan
Schutz zugesagt sollte da ein Angriff
Drohnen aus Peking es sind auch Waffen
geliefert worden und ich sage mal wenn
da was kommen würde dann müsste waschen
Wort halten
im Prinzip ja aber ich denke was wir aus
diesem Konflikt im Moment sehr sehr
deutlich lernen ist nicht nur dass die
USA zu ihren Bündnisverpflichtungen
stehen sondern eben auch das sogenannte
Sicherheitsgarantien wie sie ja auch so
mancher fordert eigentlich wertlos sind
wenn wir uns erinnern an das Memorandum
von Budapest 1994 die Ukraine gibt alle
ihre Nuklearwaffen ab dafür erhält sie
Sicherheitsgarantien sowohl von Russland
als auch von westlichen Staaten so 20
Jahre später 2014 sehen Sie was diese
sogenannten Garantien wert sind das
heißt also wenn wir Stabilität haben
wollen in der Welt dann führt eigentlich
an diesem Weg nichts mehr vorbei also
entweder muss man die Räume und Staaten
die man schützen will aufrüsten
möglicherweise sogar nuklear aber auf
jeden Fall wird man Ihnen glaubwürdige
militärische Unterstützung leisten
müssen im Fall von Taiwan ist das vor
allem eine Aufgabe für die pazifische
Flotte der USA aber ich denke China wird
sich sehr genau überlegen
ob es weiterhin solche drogenmanöver
ausübt gegenüber Taiwan weil wir in der
Ukraine eben sehen zum ersten Mal
wirklich mit Gewalt und mit Nachdruck
dass es euch ein Verhalten nicht mehr
toleriert werden wird ja das war der
militärökonom Markus Matthias Keup und
ich bedanke mich für Ihre Einschätzung
nach Zürich danke
danke schönen Abend